this is no no this is about how people
feel hey guys I'm off the grid for
August this is a general intro to a
video of Democrats doing something
stupid this upright you are not
interested in being a candidate for
president technically yourself right now
or are you that's a fair statement okay
what I'm technically and legitimately
doing is representing I'm a
representative and I'm representing what
I believe to be the majority of the
country that wants to turn the page
tired of the meanness and the
fear-mongering of Donald Trump I would
like to see Joe Biden and a wonderful
and remarkable man past the torch uh
cement this extraordinary language you
don't want him to run for reelection I
believe what's in the best interest of
the country and by the way this is not
how everybody thinks but I do believe a
majority wants to move on I hear from
way too many people now this is the news
was that I was meeting with donors the
fact is I listen to normal Americans
every day and my own feelings this is no
no this is about how people feel by the
way it's not about what's real all the
time it's about how people feel people
want to turn the page I think that's
fair to say as a Democrat I adore Joe
Biden he saved this country he can
cement his legacy my real call to action
right now is not about me
the call to action is to ask the
president to pass the torch